Dean is disappointing John Paul Jones is
screaming you manipulate tisha makes me
sick get out of my sight and we have
ruined every special occasion did JPJ
and Derek get us all kicked out of this
wedding this is your bachelor in
paradise episode 8 recap grab your
glasses if time for roses and Rose Day
hi everybody it's me Lauren Zima and I'm
still obsessed with a chilled red I put
ice on it this time oh my god I gotta be
Who I am just like Dean had to be who he
was and return to his old ways let's get
to it I love a children so much that I
wore red today you know and that is good
right we have got to be on brand Dean
didn't have to be on bread why did you
do it Dean why I was feeling so happy
and so great and so fun and everything
was so good any love let's talk about it
I mean ever excited about us and the
more I get to know him the more excited
I get
I haven't talked to you okay you guys
didn't think I'd say this but we start
off with Dean breaking up with Kaylin on
her birthday
I think that
you're an amazing awesome person and I
didn't expect to like you as much as I
do who that's that
Dean but the way that we are around each
other
like we were just like each other so
much more in tomorrow who does that who
does it why do it
why what's you how could you I just
don't understand it Dean we left off
Monday night's episode with you having
given Kaelyn a beautiful whole birthday
cake for her birthday and now we're back
to being broken into tiny pieces did she
even get a bite of the cake I hope so I
hope that after he broke up with her she
just got to eat the whole didn't cake I
lost myself there Wow
I'm so disappointed in Dean D for
disappointed Dean you don't deserve the
mustache you are not grown I know it
sucks and I feel awful about it
because I think it's probably for the
best so Dean tells their look I'm really
not ready for this I know I can't go
beyond paradise paradise and you know we
were almost there but we're going
nowhere I just think that use there's
someone better than me to be honest
where's Dean going back to his dad fine
I think I should go drink for this all
happening really quickly Dean was
upfront with Kailen Kailen was crying
and then Dean was gone um wow that's
good oh I need this right now what did
you guys think of Dean's dumping of
Kalyn I wish Kalyn had dumped him I do
he gave her the perfect out on Monday
night's episode I wish he'd just broken
up with him then it's better to be in
the power position you know the person
who hurts the most in a relationship is
the person who cares the most it's
painful but think about it it's not
wrong Dean was wrong okay I don't know
why Dean did that but while Dean is
ending things with Kalyn Jahn Paul Jones
is digging in with Taoiseach did he just
say he was in love with her very
difficult to see the woman that you know
you're in love with potentially open up
the door another guy whoa John Paul
Jones always the wild card always not
expected always confusing I mean he just
went on dates with Tijuana and Haley and
then he says he's in love with Taoiseach
the woman that you know you're in love
with I mean I'm so used to John Paul
Jones napping and cartwheeling but
suddenly he's crying
what bag is happening
he is sobbing on the beach and of all
people
Blake is there to comfort him he does an
okay job I think Blake doesn't know what
to do anymore you know he's so lost he's
just like maybe I'll try to help others
come out of so much stronger it's wild
how much of course we've come to learn
that John Paul Jones is honestly
believed John Paul Gross he's constantly
choking and vomiting and when he's
crying he blows his nose repeatedly into
what might or might not be a
handkerchief he looks more like a dinner
napkin gross I am NOT a fan of blowing
my nose in front of people it's enough
for me I know for me a nose is for me
[Applause]
don't blow your nose in front of people
okay
[Music]
validation period stations
Blake seems lost with JPJ though like
the rest of us like where is this big
reaction coming from I didn't know you
were in love with tisha this is wacky
was crazy beautiful and then speaking of
love it's a wedding
please rise Chris and Krystal got
engaged last season on paradise now they
are getting married and I gotta say
while their wedding ceremony is
beautiful
the rest of the guests is the little all
over the place did anybody tell the
bachelor in paradise cast that they will
be attending a wedding drink for every
time someone's not in wedding where I
mean Taoiseach comments on how she's
kind of in a beachy dress and Dylan
seems to literally be in a t-shirt dress
appropriately dressed for the occasion
[Music]
yeah do you want to be in a tea or do
you want to be a JC just glass
[Applause]
oh god you guys I just have to give a
hat tip to the producers on this imagine
you are just starting to develop
feelings with someone or you've just
been dumped and suddenly you're at a
wedding day out this thrust things to
the next level right Nicole and clay are
getting serious but are they serious
enough for a wedding
Kailyn has just been dumped now she's
having to watch love be realized
horrifying a great television right but
then some guys show up
chase McNary spin him in and he was from
Joe Joe season sure hi daughters here
everybody yes Connor from Hannah Browns
a season I wondered when we'd see Connor
I mean there was no way he wasn't gonna
show up on paradise and then some guy
with a man but I actually am NOT I don't
think he is was he a bachelor nation
alum who is that man so the wedding is
happening and then JPJ is JP jumping off
the deep end
he is losing it he is gone he is
freaking out over tisha and Derek really
liked Asia a lot and you know Derek was
trying to swoop in after his
relationship with Demi ended I mean just
drink to how wacky this felt Derek is
that creepy guy that you know graduated
high school five years ago and comes
back to the high school parties and
bring despite the fact he's a grown-ass
man he's creepy quite frankly John Paul
Jones has always seemed like an
easygoing guy but now he is going off
the deep end about another guy and I
don't understand because I just watched
Derek be like a super amazing respectful
graceful mature and pathetic wonderful
guy with the whole Demi thing it's not
adding up
do you agree with Jay PJ's assessment of
Derek let me know in the comments below
by the way there's gonna be some drama
with Nicole and clay because clay is
very recent ex Angela a bachelor nation
alumna is here she's walking down the
aisle she's a bridesmaid and angela is
walking County uh your girl looks good
girls got that revenge breakup by girl
is descending down the aisle with a
little swagger right I'm sure she looks
great I know I mean I guess a play
dumped her so I gotta say girl get yours
you know
by the way you guys the wedding ceremony
was beautiful the flowers these sparkles
and crystal looked gorgeous and Chris
was crying and then I was tearing up and
they loved on occasion being reminded
that I have a heart John Paul Jones is
now losing it on Derek at a wedding I
mean Jay PJ's I feel like Derek's a
mature dude you're the one raising your
voice at him at a wedding no no no hold
on with me Derek that's you know so John
Boel Joe's is acting like Derek is
pursuing Taoiseach but the truth is that
tisha was totally into Derek you know I
just can't get on board with John Paul
Jones doing this and you know we just
ruined Kalin's birthday now we're
ruining the wedding why don't we like
special occasions
my intelligence Derek can we just
celebrate each other god
by the way drink every time John Paul
Jones doesn't let Derek talk I think
that's a nice night no no no no
you're not allowed me to talk here bull
doesn't do that's the one thing that I
said that's false Derrick I'm not
insulting your intelligence you're
trying to talk your way out of this why
are the bride and groom calling all of
us over there did JPJ and derrick get us
all kicked out of this wedding and then
things get weird and they feel a little
produced but also I don't care like
Chris red don't makes this announcement
about how some people are like sitting
at a party table going to an after-party
and some people are not invited an extra
table in this party all right and at
this table you want to invite a few
people so if I call your name this will
be the table that you party I don't know
it was very confusing but you know
weddings are great to make people feel
uncomfortable right sure
reminder Connors here and we get to hear
him speak and we listen to him say to
Christina who are you hoping to see yeah
I missed that
hey mr. Connor but you know that he's
suddenly kissing Kayla and okay great
Kayla needs this killing deserves this
Kailyn got her cake but she didn't get
to eat it to boot you do you but while
Kailyn is flying high clay is falling
down things are descending clay is
calling his ex Angela his girlfriend on
accident
my girlfriend
clay who is very much with Nicole is
talking to Angela and telling her that
he still cares about her
I still do care about you a lot I mean
drink for every bonehead thing that clay
said who wants to hear that their ex
still cares about them after they were
dumped by them oh you really special
person to me in yours you're sweet like
this we hardly I just want you to be
happy no one wants to hear that clay not
Angela boy the audience
it just doesn't like make sense fire
here you can't sit here and say that
your being here is fine I'm 90 tells
Angela that breaking up with her was so
hard for him he's been the hardest it
was awesome in the hardest nights of my
life
like that was so difficult for me oh
really
was it clay really sorry bring her
struggle coming here maybe was selfish
and
I'm sorry and clay has his hand on
Angela's leg very inappropriate clay I'm
looking at my hands on my own leg here I
don't know if you can see that because
my hair is my face okay we've been
seeing you and Nicole spend the nights
together and wake up together in the
mornings in the queen-size bed okay if
you don't think your girlfriend would
feel okay seeing it don't do it today
was definitely one of the most
emotionally draining days I've ever had
but back to JPJ and Derrick John Paul
Jones is calling Derrick a frat boy and
Derrick's kind of the frat boy the
bachelor boy
I don't see that at all he doesn't seem
like a frat boy he seems like a 32 year
old man who works in finance I don't I
don't see it honestly John Paul Jones
you seem a little froggy er sorry stand
by every word I said today there's not
one thing I said that was not fast
they're arguing again and Derrick tells
John Paul Jones that he is monologuing
John years longest John you're
monologuing again nope we need to go
talk and he did do theater but John Paul
Jones is he's just coming at him this is
like the first time that I don't like
JPJ because it is super frustrating when
someone is confronting you attacking you
and they don't let you get a word in
edgewise he is literally telling Derrick
nope
and what you're doing is denying me the
opportunity I'm not letting him speak
and that's not fair you can't challenge
someone on what they've done but not
allow them to share their side of the
story
drink every time he said nope John your
monologue again we need to go talk away
from other people last time you
ambushed me in a room full of people
nope well I stand by everyone I said
drink every time he said podcast bills
is following at gossip to his podcast
throughout your podcast it's the quality
on your podcast dude what do you guys
think whose side are you on here John
Paul Jones or Derek but moving on
Caitlin says O'Connor's not here
Connors not here and I just keep trying
to get my hopes up about things because
every time I do I get disappointed in
her and we know the show is the gift
that keeps on giving and we are aware
that that means that Connor is about to
descend down those stairs and come and
hang out with Kayla and take her on a
one-on-one right and that's what is done
he goes on a date with her and they are
painting each other and I'm not sure
about how sexy that is but they're
making how did you know what again I
think Caitlin deserves this
you know what Kaylin didn't deserve
Cristina saying that Kaylin likes her
leftovers Jared does like my leftovers
life wants my - I saw three tires
why somebody would continuously go after
the guys that I'm interested in that
wasn't great Christina I think that
actually bachelor nation is just
incredibly incestual and a lot of people
hook up with each other it's not so much
leftovers it's family-style dining just
share pass the mashed potatoes it's
pretty good
Connor and kaylynn's say the painting
they made is pretty good and decent it's
not but maybe their relationship will be
what do you guys think is Kalyn gonna
end up with Connor or with Dean so Dean
and I would have never worked we could
have tried after Paradise but we would
have never worked so Kalyn says that her
and Dean would have never worked out
outside of paradise but there are lots
of rumors and reports that they're
together now so she did reach out
express that she wanted
still continue things in back to clay
and Angela Oh myself I care a lot about
and do I do because it's not like a
light switch you can't turn it off and
on clay says that his feelings for
Angela aren't a light switch he can't
just turn them on and off mm when you
break up with someone that's you turn it
off the lights it's dark in there you
gotta find it
[Music]
a little worried I mean clay if you
weren't over Angela why did you come to
paradise and also why is clay talking to
Nicole about his lingering feelings for
Angela tell a friend phone a friend find
someone else on this Beach you know I
don't want you to vent to me and work
that out with me process it elsewhere in
a different facility I'm just worried
that if Angela does come in here like
that's gonna really be weird and then oh
my god this show is the gift that keeps
on giving and by giving I mean
terrorizing but also in a great way
because we're here because we love drama
Angela arrives on the pitch I mean they
flew her all the way there you know
playing ticket to Mexico might as well
get around the beach to go then we get
the trailer and we don't know what will
happen with clay and Nicole and Angela
Colangelo Knoll and we see that Dean is
coming back so that makes sense because
we have heard that demon Kaylin heard
together now so will Dean redeem himself
let's hope so what do you guys think if
Dean tries to get back with Kaylin
should she take him let me know in the
comments below thank you so much for
being here I adore you guys I appreciate
you when it comes to this crazy thing we
called paradise you are my salvation bye